do you think it's time for call of duty  to return to World War two it looks like  Activision might agree with you I'm Tony  and this is your war-torn gamespot news  update rumors of a World War 2 based  call of duty started earlier this month  when a youtube channel called the family  gamers allegedly received leaked  marketing material for the game simply  titled call of duty world war two since  then Eurogamer has made the same claim  saying multiple sources have also  confirmed the world war two setting we  at gamespot have also heard this from  our own sources so be sure to subscribe  to be the first to know when the game  gets officially revealed Activision coo  Thomas tipple recently said that this  year's call of duty entry will take the  series quote back to its roots so World  War 2 makes perfect sense perhaps we'll  hear more at e3 for more shooter action  in the meantime you can check out the  latest episode of reboot all about Mass  Effect Andromeda  [Music]  you